kings of benidire you i know are a big
fan of
contagion which has something had this
new life
in locke does you just did you only
watch it in lockdown yeah what is it it
came up as like
number one in the world most viewed film
for that like month obviously and yeah
and i watched it i've never seen it
before but it was
trippy going like oh [__] they predicted
this yes it's just
happening now so were you did you feel
very smug when this all started
happening going well yes this is
this is exactly what i was expecting
well you know i did
figure out the are not um
now i uh i i i just felt so freaked out
i was like why
would everyone watch contagion it's
about a horrible global pandemic
in which many people die um yeah
i mean i definitely have to say i you
know i i am still in touch with the
writer scotty burns who wrote contagion
and so he was messaging me right away
because he was of course
connected to people at cdc and they were
saying it's really happening
start wearing a kn95 mask and wash your
hands for 20 seconds regularly
so he was messaging me saying it's
coming you know masks
everywhere and so i was honestly me and
my family
we were definitely wearing our masks
um quite a long time before i think a
lot of other people were
and i was in america filming at the time
i was in philadelphia
um and uh and yeah getting many funny
looks in the street people couldn't work
any of it out was that a picture of me
doing the r naught there i haven't seen
that clip for ages
i look so young and so thin you are
young and thin and beautiful now i won't
hear that kate winslet no darling listen
i've got to tell you something in
lockdown i've been
like like most people you know cooking
like crazy my ass is just
massive now but the other day i had to
i had to answer some questions for an
interview by
email so i'm answering these questions
and la
and i get to the end they're about to
press send i think oh quick spell check
and where i'd put film actress it had
auto corrected to full mattress
which i have decided
[Laughter]
[Music]
mattress
you